AND GRAB CADE.
AND A
HERE IS SWIPE BY21 POINTS.
THAT WILL PUT BACK THE
ROCKETS COME.
>> GOODNESS, CALLED ON SENGUN.
>> NO TRANSPORT
JAVONTE.
>>DUNK.
COULD HAVE BEEN
HERE COMES MEF ANY 9-69.
SHOOTING LESS THAN 40% FROM THE
FIELD.
JIM:STEPH.
>> Jim: THAT'S A FREE HAND>> Bo.
I CAN'T BLAME HIM.
>> Jim: CAUGHT THAT REVERSE. UNE
AS NORMAN POWELL PICKS UP HIS
FOURTH FOUL.
>> Kevin: HOW CAN'T YES, SIR.
YES, SIR.
ANOTHER LI
JUST
THEY HAVE NUMBERS.
ISH SMITH.
OH MY GOGO ONE FOR SHAMET.
BUT HE WENT UP WITH TWO
H.B.ROW.
LOWRY HAS IT BACK.
>> John: P.J.
TUCKER KEEPS THIS ALIVE . IT
BACK.  EXPLANATION  THIRD  BACK
WHAT T
THE ROOKIE SHOWING US HIS AERIAL
ASSAULPELLS. OFFENSE.
I LOVE HIM FACILIT
A ANGNGLELE I ISSSSUEUE..
"T"T" " HEHE W WILILLL N NOTOT P
FOUR STEALS.
ISAAC OKORO